what is 30 7/8 or wait what's 37 times 6
no matter how quick you are you take at
least a few seconds to come up with the
answers but what if you are asked for
the value of 37 divided by 10 it will be
3.7 it takes us just about a second to
answer this we just move the decimal
place one place to the left and what
about 37 multiplied by 2 it will equal
74 so division by 10 or multiplication
by 2 are fairly simple to perform so
what if I asked you to divide 44 by 5
instead of dividing 44 by 5 we can just
multiply it with 2 over 10 2 over 10 is
actually 1 over 5 and multiplying
something with 1 over 5 is the same as
dividing it with 5 and why did we do
this it's because multiplying with 2 and
dividing by 10 are relatively easier
operations so this will equal 44 times 2
divided by 10 44 times 2 is 88 and we
divided by 10 and 88 over 10 can easily
be written as 8 point 8 so instead of
dividing a number by 5 multiplying it
with 2 and dividing it by 10 is a tag
bit faster let's look at two more
examples first 122 over 5 and second
13,000 421 divided by 5 okay let me
solve the first one and you try solving
the second one on your own
divided by 5 is the same as multiplying
it with 2 and dividing by 10 so 122
times 2 is 244 and we've divided by 10
this is 24.4 try the next one
it's easy
multiplying it with 2 gives us 26,000
842 and we divided by 10 and that gives
us two thousand six hundred and eighty
four point two so this was an easier
technique to divide a number by five
multiplying by two and divide by ten
over the next two parts of this session
we will look at quicker ways to divide
numbers by 25 and 125
[Music]
you